Путін
і його Посіпаки
вони є моральними деградантами всіма
своїми діями і не лише зараз але
особливо зараз Російська Федерація
довела що вона не може лишатися ядерною
державою луон нічого з кандечка не
робиться кожний країні своя копійка
ближче до тіла аніж Можливо навіть
інститутом Нам вдалося глобально змінити
ставлення до України
про емоції в дипломатії роботу в ООН за
лаштунками і майбутнє Росії ми говоримо
з постійним представником України при
ООН Сергієм кислицею я найперше не можу
не згадати один із ваших останніх постів
у Твіттері де ви ділитися своїми
враженнями Про засідання Ради Безпеки
ООН після останнього масованого обстрілу
України яке відбулося там ви
демонструєте Можливо там трохи не
дипломатичний але красномовний жест на
адресу Путіна Росії і усієї цієї
компанії Скажіть будь ласка це такий був
ваш емоційний жест Чи це все-таки
стратегія тролінгу Росії в мене немає
жодного сумніву
в тому що і
Путін
і
його Посіпаки
вони є моральними деградантами Ну це
факт
це люди які деградували
як істоти
і які на сьогоднішній день на жаль мають
повну владу над
Російською Федерацією є
представником Путіна в радбезі
в нього є заступник його звати
Полянський він ще більш рідна істота ніж
самі і це не лише моя оцінка це є оцінка
багатьох моїх колег слухати і нібенцію і
особливо Полянського їх слухати
неможливо і я їх слухаю і Мої колеги
слухають і вже не перший місяць не
перший рік скажу також таємницею що
особливий стрес
отримують ще й перекладачі
оунівський які мають весь цей бред
перекладати слухати цих потвор дуже
складно розумієте тому що коли Ти
отримуєш інформацію не лише від
керівництва країни і керівництва МЗС а
від родичів
які знаходяться в Україні коли ти бачиш
що там відбувається а потім ти сидиш в
радбезі і люди
на рівні
єбліса і Ріббентропа
виступають це дуже складно
тому У мене немає жодної до них поваги
не людською непрофесійною тому якщо
хочете то
мої квіти в тому числі вчорашній твір
вони є
моєю особистою оцінкою
в своїх опонентів російських в
Я готовий під нею підписатися і
повторити
що я про них думаю це одна чи дуже
важливо щоб розуміли І ваше слухачі і
глядачі це одначе не відміняє
той факт
що Практично всі російські дипломати
більшість з них До речі це представники
спецслужб під прикриттям Я думаю що
представництві Російської Федерації в
нью-йорку десь 70-75%
співробітників все чисте розвідники вони
є професіоналами своєї справи У них є
Сумасшедший ресурс відносно Сумасшедший
тому що частиною з них висловили але
навіть після того як їх висловили в
російській місії при ООН працює
щонайменше 70 лише дипломатів а в
українській
українські 10 разів менше а але ще
приблизно стільки же крім 70 дипломатів
працює ще скільки вже адмін персоналу і
технічного персоналу ви розумієте що
дипломатична робота це величезний обсяг
технічної роботи тобто є потреба
упресувати обсяг навіть паперовий
величезний і робити первинну обробку
інформації або просто потрібно що
роблять росіяни в нью-йорку вони сидять
і як сканери сканують все що хто
говорить будь-яка місія що говорить для
того щоб потім вживати відповідні заходи
скажеш щось проукраїнське будь-яка там
африканська місія відразу всіх на
профілактикунзя мав свій шанс залишитися
гідною людиною відносно гідної людини
коли лише почалася
велика війна
повномасштабна агресія він не обрав Ані
свободу а не гідність він розуміє що
його опції мінімальні тому що він людина
яка наближається до пенсійного віку
на заході він ніхто Тому в нього єдиний
шлях з часом повернутися в Москву жити
на російську пенсію
ловити рибу що якщо він не піде шляхом
інших своїх попередників а його або його
не підуть шляхом його попередників він
взагалі сам вірить у те що він говорить
чи він просто виконує рознарядки
не верит це вже таке це вже він буде
потім коли проходити щонайменше свідком
на майбутніх трибуналах то він буде
розповідати як колись розповідали
нацистські дипломати
і намагалися Робити вигляд що вони
нічого не знали ні про концтабори не про
газові камери що вони там собі щиро
захищали інтереси
поневоленого за підсумками Першої
світової війни німецького народу Тому це
несуть важливо чи не вірить чи не вірить
суть важлива те що він виходить на
засідання радбезу або будь-який інший
російський дипломат виходить на
засідання радбезу і говорить все все під
запис
принципово важливість
засідань відкритих зокрема радбезу
що вони йдуть он де Рекорд
і все що говорить
стає так би мовити
свідченням тієї чи іншої країни
які записуються і фіксуються і ці
свідчення потім є частиною
[музика]
в тому числі доказової бази
в національних і міжнародних судах
кожне засідання Ради Безпеки передбачає
що країни-члени
і що важливо країни так звані постійні
члени Ради Безпеки
виходять на засідання
і вони мустять чітко директор
при тому що слухає критична вся планета
за винятком напевно на Північної Кореї
до Інтернету немає
заявити пропозицію свого уряду
щодо події зокрема щодо обстрілів
ракетних українців це до речі одна з
причин чому деякі країни говорять час
від часу і ви могли можливо чули в Раді
безпеки що надо вести дипломатію нашу ми
тут збираємося Ради Безпеки скільки
можна їх збирати тому що вони почувають
себе дуже Ніяково від того що вони мають
як кажуть англійською мовою exposs свою
позицію
а подекуди вони не можуть зайняти чітку
позицію або не хочуть займатическо
позицію А як Україні працювати з такими
державами з такими державами як той
самий Китай чи з державами Африки дуже
великий Континент дуже багато держав які
так само висловлюються якщо не нараді
безпеки то в генеральній асамблеї і
своєю кількістю мають великий вплив
роботи ідеться і в столицах робота
ведеться і тут в нью-йорку
але я хочу вас зупинити Що практично
жоден з пас слів
немає можливості самостійне приймати
рішення не китайські не
французькі тобто критичне будь-яке
голосування в раді безпеки воно
узгоджується чи в генеральній асамблеї
воно узгоджується зі столицями Для
прикладу наприклад візьмемо резолюцію
про репарації резолюцію
яка містить положення і про
компенсаційні питання і про
реєстр для багатьох країн було дуже
складно
узгодити свою позицію на відміну від
скажімо чисто політичної резолюції яка 2
березня ухвалювалася і йшлося про
агресію пам'ятаєте 2 березня Ми ухвалили
резолюцію 140 країн проголосувала і
визнала російську федерацію України
мрсром
то
резолюція по репараціях набрала менше
голосів тому що коли вже мова йде про
гроші Коли вже мова йде про заморожений
активи тут не лише зовнішньополітичний
відомства мають дати зелене світло в
кожній країні тут багатьох країнах
це рішення і позиція
генеральної асамблеї має бути узгоджено
і з міністерствами фінансів і з
міністерством юстиції з податковими
службами А якщо ви вже згадали цю
резолюцію про репарації то 94 країни
якщо не помиляюся підтримали її чи ви
очікували взагалі на таку підтримку коли
готувала цей документ роботи на
трипераційною
резолюцію тривало багато місяців Це була
непроста дуже змістовна дуже багато
раундів проходило доводилося наші
делегації їздити
як човники між нью-йорком Парижем
нью-йорком Лондоном
вагою між нюрками берліном дуже багато
зробив і Дмитро куліба який якраз
співпала з першим
турне великим міністри закордонних справ
України по Африці тому я вважаю що
позиція деяких африканських країн
значною мірою стала більш
проукраїнською після цього візиту це
було предметом розмов і президента
Зеленського з лідерами держав
і керівника офісу президента тому що на
певних етапах Ми стикалися з тим що без
якогось вольового рішення політичного
найвищого політичного керівництва тієї
чи іншої країни ми не могли рухатися
далі тому я вважаю що досягнутий
результату 94 Він дуже потужний для
такої тематичної
резолюції де не просто потрібно кинути
лозунг що ми за Статут ООН А де наслідки
вже сягають якихось практичних речей
практичних грошей
кожний країні своя копійка
ближче до тіла аніж Можливо навіть
інститутом подекуди розумієте що на
практиці ця резолюція по символічний
документ який ухвалила генасомлея що
вона дасть Україні
вона не є символічною би вона була
символічною знаєте Ми би не проводили
перемовини оскільки місяців я радше маю
на увазі що будь-який документ який
уваги на асамблея він не юридично
обов'язково для держав Так це правильно
не обов'язково
але
ви можете подивитися матеріали судів і в
газів і в страсбурзі і національних
судів
де не лише адвокати
посилаються на рішення генеральної
асамблеї а її прокурори посилаються на
рішення генеральної асамблеї Тому
рішення генеральної асамблеї вони є
системоутворюючі багато рішень тих же
самих політичних рішень генерального
асамблеї вони потребують національної
імплементації
дуже часто потребує рішення парламенту
національного і тоді уряд виходить і
каже
140 країн проголосували позиція світова
з цього питання от є такою або там 94
проголосувала за цю резолюцію а Росію
наприклад підтримала там чотири країни
для багатьох парламентарів парламентарів
все ж політики
дуже важливо бути на правильній стороні
паркану як кажуть англійською мовою
і те обставина що за російську позицію
голосують такі потужні
демократії експерти бо я Північна Корея
знаєте там Сирія
хто з європейських політиків в
парламенті буде опанувати бажанню уряду
ритм цементувати резолюцію щодо
репарацій
посилаючись на позицію Північної Кореї
Тому це все частина дуже капіткої роботи
яка має свою логіку і вона може не мати
миттєвий результат але вона потрібна для
того щоб запустився ланцюг подальших дій
удавенко який був колись пострадам дуже
поважно тут і головою генеральної
асамблеї свого часу
Він завжди казав і Я повторюю це дуже
часто що long нічого з кандечка не
робиться
ви не можете увірватися генерального
асамблею
кинути Кинути на стіл якусь ініціативу
або проект
і тут же його ухвалити і
мати результат
Нам вдалося глобально змінити
ставлення до України давайте згадаємо
14-й рік коли
Російська Федерація здійснила спробу
незаконний анексії Криму якщо ви
піднімете і виступи які тоді лунали в
залі генеральної асамблеї і порівняєте з
тими оцінками і з тими виступами які
сьогодні на сьогоднішній день лунають в
залі генеральної асамблеї
ви побачите наскільки ідеологічно
змінилися глобальне ставлення до
Російської Федерації як до країни
агресора а оцінка міжнародної
співтовариством діють Російської
Федерації вона поступово наближається до
оцінки дій
нацистського уряду
[музика]
наприкінці 30 і 40-х років минулого
століття
Це є дуже важливо оці резолюції про
країну-агресора від 2 березня резолюція
про оцінку спроби проведення так званих
референдумів і анексії коли ми набрали
143 голоси резолюція про репарації вона
наближає нас до того моменту коли будуть
притягатися до відповідальності
першої особи
ідіологи всього злочину агресії проти
України
ви не забувайте дуже важливий елемент що
якщо
Німеччина на сьогоднішній день є
стовпом демократією то це стало можливим
в тому числі
якщо не в першу чергу завдяки тому що
45-му році Німеччина була окупована і
під час окупації відбулася
процедура денацифікації
денацифікація Це був дуже боляче
процес який охоплював і збройні сили і
систему адміністрування урядування і
система освіти і систему навіть охорони
здоров'я
Релігійне життя Російська Федерація не
буде окупована за жодних обставин
принаймні мені невідомо про те що в
будь-якому уряді світа або розвідці або
в міністерстві оборони або в генштабі
хтось навіть
думав про таке тобто
напевно моє етапі цієї війни ми матимемо
ситуацію коли
Росія буде військовому плані розбити а
на території України
відкинути за межі державного кордону
і на по той бік державного кордону
будуть продовжувати існувати Злочинний
режим
який не зможе пройти де путінізацію
в умовах окупації або в умовах
зовнішнього контролю
І тоді виникає питання
як нам з цим жити Ти не тільки нам як
жити в цьому всьому колективному
демократичному світу
і голова болить у всіх усіх урядах і в
Берліні і Вашингтоні і в Києві
і в Парижі
тому що всі усвідомлюють
що якщо ми дамо можливість
цьому злочинному режиму навіть
розгромленому військовому плані на
території України
жити і далі за своїми правилами
відновити
або навіть Я б сказав не відновити а
реформувати російську армію
вигнати всіх генералів дегенератів
тих що розграбували російську армію і
довели її до стану повної відсутності
боєздатності місцями
то пройде 5-7 років Вони будуть мати
відносно нормальну армію
накопичення критичної маси
політичних і юридичних рішень
надзвичайно важливе для того щоб
не було повернення після військової
Параски Росії на території України до
медальності відносин з Росією як бізнеси
з Южном ви говорите про військо казку
Росії це означає що ви Не вірите у те що
якісь можливості для переговорів чи
дипломатії залишилися на даний момент
вихід на кордоні 91-го року щонайменше і
в ідеалі Мені здається дуже важливим є
питання
демілітаризації
або щонайменше створення
демілітаризаційної зони на російському
боці кордон
Ну і
Я вважаю що нарешті Російська Федерація
має бути позбавлена
статусу ядерної держави тому що саме
статус ядерної держави вводить
[музика]
супер
багато столиць
в тому числі деяких наших партнерів
всіма своїми діями і не лише зараз але
особливо зараз Російська Федерація
довела що вона не може залишатися
ядерною державою і вона має бути не
тільки
має пройти не тільки через процес до
путінізації Вона має пройти через процес
де нуклеаризації якою буде роль ООН у
цьому для воєнному регулюванні вже
уявити собі що
повоєнне врегулювання може бути
досягнуте лише проведення Саме тут
п'ятірки всі мірки там сімки чи навіть
19 країн неможливо тому що
стали врегулювання і сталі запобіжники
можуть бути досягнутими лише у взаємодії
практично з усіма країнами світу і
несуть важлива чи вони знаходяться
Латинській Америці в Африці чи деінде
тому ООН буде залишатися
глобальною платформою для цих дискусій
це не означає що ООН є
досконалим механізмом більше того він є
недосконалим механізмом який був
створений за підсумками Другої світової
війни реформування ООН глибинне
неможливе без
зміни позиції щодо реформування ООН
постійних членів але тоді ви запитаєте
мене така що ж робити з Російською
Федерацією яка типу
має право
Ну насправді
наша позиція
яку я багато разів озвучував і позиція
на керівництво держави що Російська
Федерація не може бути
постійним членом Ради Безпеки через те
що вона порушила
і порушує далі систематично всі
найпринциповіші
вимоги до не тільки до постійного члена
а в принципі до члена ООН що вона займає
місце Радянського Союзу Там не дуже
законно займає місця Радянського Союзу
Це була змова за лаштунками
невеликою кількістю країн
[музика]
які собі вирішили в грудні
91-го року що можна не питати навіть
колег порадбезу бо не було засідань
формальних радбезу хребець ніколи не
тільки не голосував і навіть не проводив
засідання на тему Чи може Російська
Федерація зайняти місце Радянського
Союзу
і не було голосувань відповідної
генеральної асамблеї відтак це було
неправий рішення не юридичне рішення а
політичне рішення
але його тоді моя наступна що якщо це
було політичне рішення то немає йти мова
і про юридичне рішення розв'язання
проблеми присутності Російської
Федерації вердбезі
необхідно прийняти
політичне рішення знову ж таки як це
було у 91-му році
і
єдине політичне рішення яке будь-яка
притомна людина може підтримати визнати
що Російська Федерація не може
Виконувати обов'язки
постійного члена Я вважаю що Never Say
Never і навіть якщо сьогодні
в цих селищах немає апетиту для того щоб
про це говорити Ну ви знаєте
невідомо що буде
1 лютого наступного року
тому подивимося Російська Федерація
стоїть на межі громадянської війни
всередині країни в цьому глибоко
переконаний
там достатньо
як було в 17-му році що там було газета
іскрамі
пожилимо побачимо Дякую за ваш стриманий
оптиміз
м цю розмову і за те що приділили нам
час Дякую вам за інтерес до Організації
Об'єднаних Націй